they're rolled out of the Confederate
flag is on its way out
someone has to reassure southern men
wondering what they're going to run up
and down their poll that they still have
their sister's hand
new rule the developers of the sex doll
capable of blinking opening its mouth
and having a conversation with you must
realize that the whole point of having
sex with a doll is that afterward no
one's asking you what are you thinking
you know you're a loser when you drop
ten grand on one of these dolls and
after sex it says We Need to Talk
new rule now that Pizza Hut
has introduced its hot dog pizza with 28
hot dogs baked into its crust Americans
have - you know what [ __ ] it I don't
care anymore eat it eat the whole thing
by yourself drop dead at an early age
for all I care
it's one fewer person out here who needs
water
new road the inventor of cowboy boots
sandals
has to ask himself why didn't anyone
think of this before and then answer his
own question because it's ugly and
stupid new rule since a million readers
have bought gray fifty shades of gray as
told by Christian other writers have to
rip off their own books by selling them
again from a different characters point
of view jaws from the Sharks point of
view snacks heaven is for real from
God's point of view go homie a little
bastard Jurassic Park from the point of
view of a dinosaur The Omnivore's
Dilemma